what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we'll be
talking about the latest developments in
the block holders story including all
the speculation that the story could be
nearing its end
personally I don't agree that the story
is ending it is a popular manga with a
ton of potential and I certainly do not
want to see it end any time soon with
that said in the latest chapters of the
manga the single biggest conflict that
has been taking place since the series
began has seemingly wrapped up and many
people are wondering where the story
could possibly go from here I've been
seeing your comments asking this exact
question on many of our black clover
videos so in this video I will be
addressing your concerns and discussing
some of the possible directions that the
story can take from here if you enjoy
the block clover content on this channel
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest black
clover news and updates and finally this
video will be dealing with the latest
developments in the black clovers story
sold this video will contain manga
spoilers please proceed with caution you
have been warned
okay so in Chapter 213 of the manga we
finally got what appears to be a pretty
definitive conclusion to the primary
conflict of the black clover story since
the very beginning if you recall all the
way back to Heath Grice who is
introduced in chapter 6 of the manga he
was a villain who was a member of the
eye of the Midnight Sun for the next two
hundred-plus chapters the story has
revolved around the eye of The Midnight
Sun its leader lifts a cape a tree the
elves that Patri wants to resurrect in
order to exact revenge on humans because
of the elf Massacre and the actual truth
about the elf Massacre that we only
learned after the introduction of the
word magic devil so if we think about it
the entire story has been progressing
towards this major battle against the
devil and now seemingly that conflict is
resolved the devil has been defeated the
elf souls have finally found peace and
everything is finally going back to
normal
naturally this led a lot of people to
wonder what will happen now is this the
beginning of the end for the entire
story and if not where does the story go
from here now that the major conflict
which has been unraveling for over 200
chapters is finally over well first of
all we don't know for sure that this
conflict is completely over some
additional twist involving the word
magic devil could always be revealed
later since we know that this devil
isn't easy to kill and that he already
managed to resurrect himself once after
500 years of being dormant with all the
twists and turns that we have seen occur
during this whole elf saga I wouldn't be
too surprised if it turns out that not
everything is as it seems but even if
this really is it for the devil and even
if this epic saga really is completely
over I am certain that this is not the
end of black clover after all Austin you
know still haven't resolved their epic
rivalry to become the wizard king and
the one important thing that black Cobra
has going for it is its expansive and
extremely interesting world building now
if we were talking about a slice-of-life
high school anime and we suddenly had
all the main characters graduating from
high school in the manga then you would
be right to think that this might be the
end for the entire story rarely
slice-of-life high school stories do
continue after high school as was the
case with Clannad after story for
example but usually when such a major
change occurs the story will soon come
to an end however black clover is most
certainly not a slice-of-life high
school anime black clover does not take
place in a very specific and limited
setting that has a clear time limit for
how long the main characters can stay
there if the main characters are
students they have to finish school and
graduate eventually so that puts a time
frame on how long the story can keep
going in the same direction but black
clover takes place in an expansive
fantasy world that has almost unlimited
potential for new plot points and plot
twists with the devil defeated with all
the mysteries surrounding the elf
massacre revealed and with the elves
finally finding peace and willfully
leaving the bodies that they had been
possessing it is a bit daunting to try
to figure out where the story will go
from here after being used to this one
specific plot line for over 200 chapters
I understand why some fans are worried
but if you are worried just hear me out
for a minute
in the world of black clover it is
already established that there are
foreign nations including ones that are
close to the clover Kingdom and ones
that are far away such as the Land of
the Rising Sun it is also established
that there are ancient forms of magic
and dungeons that conceal this type of
magic so there are still many potential
mysteries within the clover kingdom
itself that can take the story in a new
and interesting direction not to mention
that we still don't even know who the
vice-captain of the black ball squad is
and I'm sure that that will become an
important plot point sometime in the
future finally with the introduction of
the word magic devil as a major villain
we learned that alternate dimensions
exist within the world of black clover
and that in some of these dimensions we
can find extremely powerful and evil
creatures like the devil himself
under certain circumstances these
creatures are capable of travelling into
the human world
possessing humans and objects and even
fully incarnated into this world with
the help of a five leaf grimoire like
the devil managed to do what's more we
also learned that the demon within osdas
grimoire is also a creature from another
dimension
pastas demon appears to be the same type
of creature as the word magic devil and
they appear to originate from the same
dimension from the brief dialogue
between Asta's demon and the devil it
seems that the devil is Austin's demon
senior meaning that he is older or
perhaps has a higher rank but this also
implies that these two demons are
definitely not the only demons out there
the dimension that they come from may
have thousands or even millions of these
types of demons and devils and some may
be even more powerful than the word
magic devil in fact there are still so
many mysteries surrounding the demon
inside of asters grimoire we all know
about his power to create anti magic and
nullify other forms of magic with it but
there are other powers that this demon
possesses that we don't even fully
understand yet such as when asta was
able to use the demon destroyer sword to
read Potteries memories enter his mind
and communicate with him on the inside
if fastest demon is capable of doing
this and we only just learned about it a
few chapters ago then what else is he
capable of doing and what is asked us
daemon truly after what are his ultimate
goals and motivations is Asta's demon
just interested in taking over austin's
body like he seems to
apply during Oscars fight against LOD
rose or is he after something else
entirely and if he is after Austin's
body what if at some point in the story
he succeeds in taking over hasta I'm
just talking hypothetically at this
point but maybe something bad will
happen to someone that hasta cares about
and this will lead him into despair
which will allow the demon to take over
if this happens we'll hasta the main
character and hero of the story become
the ultimate villain whatever happens I
am certain that Austin's devil his
mysterious origins and his true
intentions are going to become the main
subject of a future arc I just can't
imagine that such massive mysteries
could go unanswered and beyond the demon
there are so many other unsolved
mysteries out there the witch queen is a
character that is extremely mysterious
and I can definitely see her popping up
again in the near future
furthermore we still don't know whether
the demon dimension is the only
alternate dimension out there or whether
even more dimensions exist and these
dimensions could contain future threats
and challenges for Austin and the black
balls finally with the wizard king
Julius Noah chrono meeting his tragic
and during the elf saga at the hands of
Patri we still have the lingering
question of who will be the next wizard
king without a competent wizard king
like Julius the entire clover kingdom
will be at the mercy of the incredibly
pompous and inept king Augustus Kira
clover and that would cause a great deal
of social and political problems so Anu
qualified wizard King must be appointed
soon but as much as they want to become
the wizard King both Austin you know are
still too young and still nowhere close
to attaining a rank high enough to
become the wizard king so who will have
to replace Julius will it be Fugo Leon
no Zell silva will it be Yami or someone
else entirely this is another lingering
question that I've been wondering about
and by all means let me know who you
believe will be the next Wizard king
after Julius down in the comments below
this question will definitely be the
subject of a future arc sometime soon as
mentioned earlier I can definitely see
why some people are worried about where
the story will go from here since one
epic saga has spanned pretty much the
entire story
so far nevertheless I would not be
worried if I was you as I said black
Homer has already established a vast and
extremely interesting fantasy world full
of mysteries and new potential for
interesting plot points and plot twists
so Yuki Tabata will have plenty of
options for the story in the future
personally I'd love to know more about
the demon inside of Ava's grimoire about
the alternate dimensions and about the
witch queen but let me know what you
guys think
where will the story go from here and
what plot point do you want to see
explored further let me know down in the
comments if you enjoyed this video you
want to see more black clover content on
this channel please leave a like to let
me know and if you're new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell also be sure to
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest black
clover news and updates a huge thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons for
supporting our work i want to give a
special thank you to our pro hero tear
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
and King's elders another huge thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
baby ray ace ingrid ah a Lola nada madam
AK and makoto-kun and at the very
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness
the tier reserved only for legends a
massive thank you to Reagan Harrison a
disciple of Lords we go himself if you
guys feel that our content provides
value for you and you want to support
more be sure to check out our patreon
link in the description even donating a
single dollar will give you access to
our anime up for patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]